je dois vous avouer que je ne suis pas
surprise moi j'avais vécu la CMP sur les
retraites alors que qui était beaucoup
moins dramatique le sujet était grave
mais beaucoup moins dramatique que
celui-là mais enfin ça ne ça ne se
décide pas en CMP on le sait bien ça se
décide dans des alcoves des
arrière-couloirs des voilà des
discussions secrètes ou moins secrète
voilà donc c'est oui mais c'est là si
vous voulez ça prend une ampleur
particulière
et ce qui est terrible aussi c'est que
moi je vis très très mal c'est de voir à
quel point le gouvernement se met dans
la main des LR les LR
qui aujourd'hui ont 62 députés à
l'Assemblée
nationale on fait moins de 5 % à la
présidentielle je suis pas du tout en
train de me moquer je suis socialiste
hein donc voilà mais je je ne comprends
pas comment un courant de pensée qui
aujourd'hui et si peu représenté dans la
société puisse influencer de cette
manière le gouvernement al bien sûr
quand je dis que je ne comprends pas si
je comprends je comprends parfaitement
tout ce qui se passe derrière mais enfin
je trouve que d'un de d'un projet de loi
qui n'avait pas d'utilité première
puisque on a fait le comptein depuis je
crois une trentaine d'années on a un
rythme de loi sur l'immigration qui est
une loi tous les 18 mois à peu près donc
d'un projet de loi qui ne qui n'a qui
n'avait pas une nécessité première qui
au départ ne revêtait pas si quand même
à part l'ame mais encore que c'est c'est
le c'est le Sénat qui l'a
rajouté de de de chose de choses
capitales j'ai envie de dire on en fait
un sujet d'une d'une telle gravité on
jette l'eauprre notamment sur des
travailleurs et ça ça me désole comment
ne pas accepter que des gens qui
travaillent
en France et dont et dont la société a
absolument besoin comment peut-on
tolérer l'idée que on ne va pas les les
régulariser comment accepter l'idée
qu'on va priver de prestations sociales
des des gens qui sont là
depuis plusieurs mois qui travaillent
qui sont des travailleurs réguliers qui
cotisent et on on va les priver de de
prestations sociales enfin je je me
demande dans quel pays je suis
aujourd'hui je reconnais pas mon pays
voilà j'ai mal à ma
France